c'est en deux jours que l'on commémorera
le triste anniversaire de la catastrophe
de tchernobyl depuis vendredi nous vous
proposons une série de reportages
aujourd'hui patrick esther eric jeanne
et dresse un état des lieux sur les
conséquences sanitaires de cette
explosion
vingt ans après les populations de la
région paye toujours le prix fort de la
radioactivité pas seulement dans les
zones à risque
interdite vingt ans après l'explosion
autour de la centrale de tchernobyl
l'accès aux zones contaminées reste très
contrôlés à l'entrée comme à la sortie
dans un rayon de 10 km les hommes ont
fui
seuls des hordes de chiens redevenus
sauvages conteste le territoire à des
meutes de loups ou à des sangliers
imposant malgré la radioactivité en
vingt ans la nature a repris ses droits
les arbres envahissent les maisons et
pour éviter que des habitants vous
reviennent s'installer dans ces villages
les autorités ont décidé de les raser
complètement délayé par la pluie et la
neige lavé par les hommes
la radioactivité décroît un peu en
surface mais elle continue à s'infiltrer
vers la nappe phréatique
ici on a des sols qui sont plutôt de
nature sableuses et cette migration
verticale se faire relativement
rapidement jusqu'à des profondeurs alors
à 1 à 2 m par contre déclaré diop tivité
rencontre des couches contiennent
beaucoup de matière organique
elle se stabilise et reste là la
radioactivité et reste ici présentes
pour le césium et le strontium pour des
centaines d'années pour le plutonium
encore bien davantage
donc il semble assez irréaliste
d'envisager le réhabiliter ces zones et
de les réinvestir ou de les rendre à
l'agriculture et pourtant dans la zone
des 30 km des habitants sont revenus
en biélorussie notamment des vieux mais
aussi des familles avec des enfants dans
le secteur russe
une équipe scientifique française
participe a suivi de 50 enfants au moyen
d'une camionnette laboratoire passant
parmi les villages
chez les enfants qui vivent sur ces
territoires contaminés on observe des
pathologies de type le trouble du rythme
cardiaque des cataractes des ulcères
gastro dieuze hainaut et des anémies ses
enfants se contaminent par le césium 137
qu'ils incorporent de façon chronique en
mangeant les aliments qui sont des
produits du potager
donc l'objectif de l'étude qu'on a mis
en place vise à établir s'il existe oui
ou non un lien entre ce niveau de
contamination par le césium 137 et ses
pathologies inhabituellement observé
chez ces enfants en biélorussie ukraine
et russie
quatre cent cinquante villages ont été
rasés mais au moins trois millions de
personnes vivent encore dans des zones
très contaminées l'hôpital russe de
briansk reçoit 1200 malades chaque jour
le tiers sont des personnes exposées
quotidiennement aux radiations
ici la mortalité dépasse la natalité les
cas de leucémie sont quatre fois plus
nombreux que dans le reste de la russie
les maladies cardiaques explose ainsi
que les maladies respiratoires et
digestives
les enfants sont atteints de cataracte
une maladie des yeux qui concerne
habituellement uniquement des vieillards
et ce n'est pas tout nous assistons à
une augmentation des cancers du sein et
nous devons les détecter le plus tôt
possible comme nous l'avions fait pour
les cancers de la thyroïde
car à ce terrible tableau il faut
ajouter des milliers de cancers de la
thyroïde
opéré à la chaîne à l'hôpital de minsk
quant aux malformations multi observé à
la maternité de gomel il n'est pas
prouvé qu'elles sont liées à la
contamination
sur mes deux autres en ce sens